this is a disgusting video bring out the
Disney Dill's disgusted myself with
James
Tiana's dad from whence US and a fraud
be chanted oh he's a no he is a
certified yes yes sorry he's emotionally
stable he knows how to work hard
his beignets he's got style he's got
grace he would never cheat on you
yeah got a nice like deep husky voice
baby James whisper in my ears waited man
that is a man right there with that
Southern drawl else is dead who I've
truly never really thought about that
[ __ ] Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
the mustache the sideburns no not a doof
she looks creepy he looks like he wears
Reeboks 504 it's like look in the box
those sideburns gotta go tiny mustache
gotta go who else is dead in general
gotta go
okay I'm fossa Mufasa Mufasa age-old
question like why are the Lion King
characters a little bit hot a little bit
a lot of it Mufasa is hot he's got nice
hair look at that main the lioness you
would be all up in that he's that like
dad that takes the kid up at school yeah
he's a top notch go any faster my life
you could hide my sin but this one I'm
not even under like way into I'm like
I'm mad I'm giving it a zero already
I'm finding Nemo [ __ ] Marlin Oh
Marlin I'm going home let's make a lot
of emotional baggage which I don't want
to take on
you'll be like doing gonna be like words
look at his Facebook first of all it's a
[ __ ] clown fish as a fish she's not
even that hot I feel like I've seen
hotter fish wouldn't email gets put in
the tank and there's that guy who's like
really dark and mysterious that guy is
fish I get Marlin off my screen Oh
Tarzan's their eyes instead okay this
whole family is beautiful hot
Tarzan's like that family we're like the
grandpa the dad
Tarzan his son they're all fine the long
hair and the mustache the muttonchops
it's like 18th century he's sexy swag he
lives in the jungle that's hot
in Greek it would be passionate as Mars
ends at 10 attend I don't know if we'll
find a DILF hotter than him
DILF meet her Riley's dad from inside
out which we all know he's a certified
no hold the butt though you're gonna do
that ass you mean you didn't pause this
scene when you were watching the movie
he just looks like he's like I'm cool
right like it's lit you're gonna say dad
this is what a dad is yeah we just like
make a really bad dad joke like he might
be a little boring yeah but still hot it
looks like you probably would you know
works at Charles Schwab give this like a
7 thank you for blessing us pic sorry I
just hope we're not the only ones out
there who like looking at these nails
like what they had going on over there I
hope that the whole world can join us in
this discovery I can confirm after doing
this video BuzzFeed has run out of ideas
thank you everyone thanks for tuning in
[Music]